[Music]
okay everybody so this is my review of
the wheel of time finale the eye of the
world okay so i was very hyped for this
episode and i had said in my previous
review that just my whole feeling of the
season as a whole is going to depend a
lot on this finale because i feel like
there's a lot of setup and you want big
reward unfortunately i found myself
pretty disappointed with this finale one
of the main reasons is i felt like there
was a lack of urgency in both areas in
this episode where it was
moraine and rand in the blight or
whether it's this army preparing for
battle
with these monsters coming and
i felt like it was bizarre how much of a
lack of urgency there was
and i also thought it was bizarre how
much dialogue the
leader of this army and his sister had
in this final episode because i really
did not care much about them and i felt
like we haven't had nearly enough screen
time before this to feel any weight of
their dialogue in this episode and also
if you want to sell it on you know at
least giving him a good story arc the
leader in one episode we got more that
with a sister she has this big moment at
the end as a sacrifice but
he just you know shoots his bow a couple
times and gets killed you know what a
letdown and
that's even just this buildup of the
army versus the monsters where
you know nothing really happened with
them it was a couple shots of bow and
arrows and that was kind of it so
that just felt off and don't even get me
started on especially this episode
how bad
the monsters looked here they looked way
better in episode one i mean there's no
excuse for this
the budget this show had you're like
where is that money going you know is it
giving the crew gift cards to costco
like what what's happening here i mean
it's 20 22 in a week lord of the rings
the two towers came out 2002. now
imagine a scene from that that's similar
to you know monsters running at a wall
like the battle of helms deep and
compare it here yeah it's different it's
a movie budget compared to tv but the
amount of money that they could have at
least put in that they've been given
then many shows don't have to make this
look not like i'm watching a cut scene
in a ps3 video game it just looked bad i
mean even when the monsters had the
practical effects when they were running
up
through the eyes of some of the warriors
and they got onto the wall of the
monsters they looked literally like the
monsters from march of the wooden
soldiers
[Music]
that's not good that's going backwards
you know we want to go forwards we want
to take that money and make us see
something we haven't seen before at
least make it
up to par so it doesn't be that bad that
it takes you out of it and there was all
this hype you know just for them going
into the blight and not much happens
there it's not that scary there wasn't a
lot of obstacles the coolest part was
rand having this dream
and
we got to see the dark one like stabbed
through moraine's mouth it was a cool
fake out but they had land go after them
and he easily goes through the blight we
didn't see any obstacle for him so he
was completely
not used in this finale and
that was just unbelievable to me how
silly that came off where he just got to
marine with no like with ease i mean
sure we consume this great you know
water but i need to see something i need
to see this blight given obstacle these
people and it even goes to
disappointment of this big you know
showdown between the dark one and rand
here where they went for more of the
angle which you've seen a lot where
someone's kind of an alternate reality
this is something that looked like the
dark one was taking the role of like the
devil in the suit kind of vibe here with
the temptation for him and make this
world happen through his power and i
just thought that the problem with
making that choice and that effect
it took away from the physicality of the
action here
with moraine rand and the dark one it
didn't feel big it didn't feel like this
epic finale it just felt so
like bland and again maureen has all
this talk about anyone who's not the
dragon that goes here will die and even
if she doesn't die herself you know it's
like she got out of this without a
scratch yes she lost her attachment to
the one power but it's like i didn't
feel like there was any kind of
obstacles that they were actually
fighting that we see them pay for and
suffer through to have that rewarding
feeling at the end it just all felt too
easy and poor parent here i mean they
really gave him not much to do some of
his moments were just silly like i was
laughing really hard when he was just
yelling at loyal like what are we gonna
do just watch our friends die it's like
he's just him like moping this whole
time and being completely useless and
the worst thing is pat and feign
everyone predicted was this person
following them we saw that last episode
was you know confirmed it was him we see
his face but he's this peddler and he's
with the dark friends and the fades and
he kills loyal which sucks because i was
a really exciting character but all this
is happening and parents running away
from her back
what i did like though was there was a
moment of strong tension where moire in
the dark one at the end there the dark
was like he's channeling you don't even
know what he's planning to do and
mourinho's slowly cutting more into
ransom that was intense but again
there's just something missing here
maybe this would have been great
just as the last moments but we need
something else i do like that rand knows
this isn't what eguin wants in his
vision so that's kind of what makes him
see clearly and does the right thing and
then we talk about too like yes this was
intense with all these women channeling
together and
crazy moment for this warrior woman
whose face just like zaps out and dies
huge sacrifice that was cool but
again
it hurts that the special effects don't
look great it also is something that's
repetitive with the channeling that
maybe they should have made channeling
look a little different here and there
for different people it's visually
repetitive now i'm bored of it i think
it's not as interesting that's something
where you can really take
your own kind of spin on it in an
adaption into television but we see
naive sacrifices herself
which you know was foreshadowed good by
the psychic bartender seeing her like
burn up so he you don't know like his
naive gonna die here and she has this
big moment but iguain will heal her now
and save her
and that almost even felt like okay so
what was the point of just like
doing that just so she can have a
sacrificing moment and just come right
back i felt that was just not great now
it's cool that pat and fan gets this
nice monologue here and he's talking
about all five of them are focal points
for the wheel that's what moraine saw he
says that my lord saw and the lord wants
to bring balance someone will turn to
shadows maybe all of you and it shows
matt here and it sucks we're not gonna
get this actor matt but
we'll see what they cast to continue his
storyline but he's clearly going to be
someone going towards the dark and we
know like patton feign says rand is the
dragon but you all have a part to play
which i like that makes it more
interesting going forward but rand knows
that you know menu channel eventually go
crazy and they kill everyone they love
this happened the dragon before him that
is what also they set up the dragon
before him nicely with that opening
scene setting up how like the idea of it
was dangerous for men to channel in the
first place because of the access the
dark one had so that was cool and he
tells maureen she's gotta lie she's
gotta find a way to lie and tell
everyone he died here because he doesn't
want to end up hurting them but
moraine's saying to land the stone of
scratch means that this wasn't the last
battle i feel like it was the first so
okay it's setting up for future seasons
you know it's not it for the dark one
but again it didn't feel like this big
epic battle we were waiting for and all
these hours of television for this it
just fell flat now book readers commence
because you guys will have a better idea
i haven't read the books
about this teaser of the girl
on the beach being greeted by this giant
boat army moving waves give us maybe a
little teaser about it for non-book
readers like myself what that
kind of is all about but i am giving
this one a 6.9 this is sadly my least
favorite episode of the season and
they'll probably be people who don't
agree with that i'm sure a lot of people
are going to like this because at the
end of the day it probably had more
suspense in most episodes and more
action but
just looking at how they went about that
suspense in action to me was not great
and very disappointing so
let me know what you guys thought i'd
love to hear your thoughts i read every
comment try to respond as many as i can
please no book spoilers for anything
that we haven't seen already just stuff
we've already seen and yes you can give
a tease about those end credit moments
with that army in the ocean and also i'd
like to hear your season scores as a
whole i really want to hear what you
guys want to rate it one to ten i'm
giving it an 8.1
you could see my past reviews a lot of
them i gave in 8.8 but it's going to
bring down by this finale uh so it's
it's changing my view in the whole
season as a whole and that it all got to
this with not like going to that next
level kind of taking it down a notch
scares me for season two i hope they can
make it better and it scares me
the production value of this amazon
because
they're doing a lot of the ring show so
i hope they don't just use big budget
and
like again
not use it use it make it
work you know you're giving the money
there's no excuse here so again leave me
your season score episode score and
please follow me i enjoyed all your guys
this season please come with me other
shows i do i do a bunch of fantasy shows
as well other types of tv shows movies
celebrity interviews i really appreciate
every subscriber i can get it helps me
in so many ways you have no idea and if
you love what i do here i really
appreciate becoming a member today
because then it will help me do more
reviews for you guys in the future
and
you'll get special perks and please
follow me at steve r show on twitter
instagram and tick tock for more of me
and i'll see you next time